um self-isolation the date for ending uh
compulsory self-isolation the blanket
self-isolation on the 16th of august
is there any scope for bringing that
forward on a
an english basis uh and is there any
scope for expanding
the self-isolation exemptions list the
car industry has been saying that
they're suffering
a slump in production due to the
so-called pandemic for example
yeah i completely appreciate people's
frustration with all of this
but i think it's the right approach as
we exit the restrictions to do so
in a cautious way and to do so in a way
that protects us and that's what
this does the prime minister's been
clear about the date that's the right
approach
and in terms of exemptions what we have
outlined is quite a significant
set of exemptions for critical
industries critical workforces to enable
that essential part of our economy to
keep functioning but what i'd say to
people is look i know it's frustrating
please stick with it
it's just a few more weeks and then we
can i said all look forward hopefully to
a very good summer
just very quickly you you've asked the
obr to publish its fiscal forecast on
the 27th of october does that mean we
can expect a spending review or a budget
we definitely will have a spending
review in the autumn and we'll set out
the date for that in due course